The chief goal of a virtual memory system
is to provide a process with the abstraction that
it has an address space all to itself,
typically organized like this. We have addresses for the
program code. We have addresses for variables that
are initialized, literals, constants, things like that. Space for
uninitialized global variables that we expect to change over
the course of the program. Space for the heap
which is dynamically allocated and might grow or shrink over
the course of the program and space for the user
stack the procedures, local variables, all that sort of thing.
There are also addresses reserved for the kernel, we'll see
how this improves efficiency later in the lesson. The advantage
of this abstration are best seen from the compiler's perspective.
The compiler can choose an address for a local variable
or code for the body of a procedure without having
to worry about what other processes might be running on the
computer at the same time as the application is compiling. And what
physical memory those applications might be using. He gets to pretend that
the application and the OS will have the computer entirely to themselves.